[Musique]
puisque matthieu delormeau ans vous avez
perdu un pari la semaine dernière et
hier soir vous êtes donc allés passer
une nuit avec daniel daniel cayla daniel
moreau ça faisait combien d'années que
vous n'aviez pas dormi avec un garçon
peut on se contenter
il ya eu des gains la deuxième guerre
mondiale
je vais l'appeler sérieux deux secondes
très très très longtemps combien ça se
chiffre en année en disant ouais à peu
près moi ça fait neuf des dix ans qui
n'avait pas dormi à kaka son gp et avec
et mannequin attend que trois ans mon
âge alors on rappelle à nos
téléspectateurs que vous êtes une
nouvelle recrue que vous habitez avec
votre maman voilà voilà que vous n'avez
jamais connu garçons je suis ici mais je
des couches plus depuis longtemps vous
avez connu un ou deux garçons c'est ça
et il ya très longtemps
ouais voilà et de morlaàs mais vous avez
passé mais c'est j'aurais passé la nuit
avec matthieu delormeau
on va voir ça dans un instant on attend
tous avec impatience à ce que la nuit le
daniel avec mathieu je peux vous dire
c'était chaud très chaud rester plus hot
foot et plus dogues on sait qu'à 50
nuance de gris qui est sorti la main la
nouvelle version est bien
matthieu delormeau et daniel ont passé
une nuit en chambre matthieu delormeau
ça faisait comme un taux qui n'avaient
pas passé une nuit avec une dame d'une
dame 17 ans de 17 heures et vous est ce
n'est pas le chiffre exact ça donne
honnêtement non mais c'est ça doit être
à peu près on était un peu et réalité
savez pendant les bras pas à la poussée
peut-être que vous étiez peut-être déjà
ensemble on s'est pas reconnue
berne ne s'était pas de gaieté de coeur
au départ on va voir ce qu'on va voir ce
qui s'est passé cette nuit là je n'ai
pas vu des images à 50 nuance deux de
leurs maux
[Applaudissements]
le
chanson facile facile ça fait 30 ans que
j'attends ce moment tu crois pas qu'il
viendra t on fait quoi ce soit a prévu
crois tu dis n'est pas loin 30 euros
j'aime mieux un petit chèque coeur de
compter quinze sorties pour tous j'ai
pas faire payer 60 euros
alors tu en sais comment imagine
maintenant temps que mon appel
kader le tunisien je suis prête
c'est bien s'est échangée sous tutelle
et maquillés aussi à non il faut
peut-être faire le calumet de l'amour
beaucoup trop dangereux ou du grand duc
à moustache
oh là là où staff des malades réservé à
beinheim ça c'est une exclu de
l'oratoire ce soir j'ai encore
distribuer des renards j'ai à vous tenir
chaud chaud tu verrais comment une kif
là-bas je reviendrai pour deux heures
dans la dent deux heures alors à mathieu
pour pierre vous aurez une sexualité
débridée ou coup mathieu je suis
[Applaudissements]
ça nous a fait du bien de voir tout ça
ça et franchement et mathieu faut que
vous précisiez un truc pour la maman de
daniel dansant rigoler votre maman qui
nous a demandé de préciser quelque chose
ce soir mathieu que la prod m'a appelé
deux fois pour dire tu précises bien
bien bien que tu n'as pas fait l'amour
avec alors c'est gentil de me de
préciser je suis pouvez y avait un doute
fait que c'est une très jolie femme mais
voilà donc je précise pour la maman de
daniel prénom je signe je suis sauvage
ou si tu nous regardes ils n'ont rien
fait voilà non et on va n'a pas fait
l'amour ensemble on se contentait de
quelques caresses haddaoui bah oui
quelques moments de tendresse v6 mais
pourquoi elle voulait pas qu'il fasse
l'amour si on perd la garantie
[Applaudissements]
oui beaucoup de choses
y'a pas de suite ah non alors accordé
mais je vais leur demander parce qu'à
mon avis c'est peut-être mal fait ou va
reculer les images qui avait des trucs
chaud non mais non non non non on va
voir ça oui moi ce que j'ai découvert
c'est que mathieu est un hyperactif
parce que vous avez part comme ça bon
c'est pas de sa faute
il aurait bien aimé rester mais il est
obligé de partir il a été hyper actifs
sauf avec moi un label jusque là il perd
passif mais c'est surtout qui en fait on
dirait comme ça que j'ai pris un râteau
énorme même pas un râteau la cabane du
jardinier entier mais c'est que c'est un
garçon débit car il disait que je ne
couche pas le premier soir dans lequel
insiste et du coup j'ai raison allez
merci
[Applaudissements]